conduire un taxi
c'est comme aller à la pêche parce que
quand on prend quelqu'un on ne sait
jamais s'il va vouloir juste faire le
tour du pâté de maisons on appelle ça un
shorty ou s'il va vouloir aller jusqu'à
auch koch rencontre tellement de gens
différents
mais en réalité on est seul à new york
les taxis font partie du paysage ils
sont au centre du système nerveux de la
ville sans eux
new york ne pourrait pas fonctionner
13000 taxis jaunes 240 millions de
passagers transportés chaque année 2
milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires et 42000 chauffeur de taxi 82
% environ des kabyles
les chauffeurs de taxis jaunes sont des
étrangers attirés par le rêve américain
[Musique]
pourquoi une telle proportion d'immigrés
parce qu'on travaille en beaucoup 12 à
16 heures par jour on peut gagner
beaucoup en tout cas bien plus que dans
son pays d'origine
new york est un immense melting-pot où
tout est prévu pour assimiler les
nouveaux arrivants chaque communauté
cherche néanmoins à retrouver ses
repères ici on se sent vite chez soi
surtout si on a trouvé un bon métier à
new york
la plupart des chauffeurs commencent et
finissent leur journée au garage qui
leur loue un véhicule
on constate au garage que les chauffeurs
ne sont pas tous des immigrés récents
il faut régate près de 99% des
chauffeurs de taxi new yorkais sont des
hommes restent 1%
gilles faveur c'est une évolution
naturelle dans ma vie d'être devenu
chauffeur de taxi avant de rejoindre le
monde des taxis la plupart des
chauffeurs ont accumulé des expériences
très différentes
j'ai fait plein de choses différentes
j'étais secrétaire médicale vendeuse
chez bloomingdale's j'ai donné des cours
de maths
[Musique]
ni milieu non bâti il n'y a pas de
filière précise qui conduisent aux taxis
il faut avant tout avoir envie de
travailler pour gagner de l'argent
hassan match dix est d'origine
palestinienne j'ai conduit des
limousines
j'ai eu un magasin et avant ça je suis
allé à la fac
un parcours un peu bizarre avec ses rues
numérotés et ses avenues rectilignes
il est facile de trouver son chemin à
new york quelle que soit leur origine
les chauffeurs de taxi connaissent vite
la ville comme leur poche ils ont appris
la langue ils ont appris les rues ils
savent ce qu'ils font ils sont
excellents
ils sont bien meilleurs que moi alors
que moi je suis né ici
[Musique]